with more on all this we're joined by ed
O'Keefe congressional reporter for The
Washington Post and a CBS News
contributor ed good morning good to see
you guys a president accused the former
director of the FBI of lying said he'd
swear to that in testimony are we headed
for the president being deposed here by
special counsel it's it's certainly
possible and there are lawmakers in both
parties who have acknowledged that that
could happen and you know I think that's
part of what was so intriguing about
commis testimony this week is that they
may he may have been laying out lines of
questioning the president will
eventually have to answer and and would
have to answer to a special counsel
under oath and and you know they've been
that's part of the concern that a lot of
Republicans have is that if he keeps
talking about this is he potentially
setting himself up for legal trouble
should he get asked these questions you
know in an official in an official way
and the tapes that the president alludes
to but will not confirm the existence of
we are going to find out about whether
they exist in a quote very short period
of time yeah
what is the strategy here in terms of
dangling this possibility out to the
press Alex I wish I knew if anything it
just just leaves the intrigue there and
the fact that these committees are
asking for the tapes by later this month
I think will at least give us a few more
days of entry goes to whether or not
they exist and you know if they don't
exist so be it if they do boy oh boy as
the former director said Laurie already
fun to listen to yeah do you think
commis testimony this week substantially
changed anybody's mind in Washington ah
well you know it certainly Republicans
now believe the president is out of you
know out from under the cloud of
criminal wrongdoing but he's certainly
not clear of any political wrongdoing
this is going to fester for quite some
time and it's going to make it very
difficult for him to really command the
agenda and and and the attention of
everyone in Washington to get things
anyone's done things are still going on
but with so much attention focused on
this it's going to be really tricky for
the White House to to change the subject
on a regular basis knowing that details
of this ongoing probe continue to leak
out and he's also set up by the
President had set up a dynamic where
it's effectively he said he said he is
denied asking James Comey for a loyalty
pledge he said I didn't say
that and if I did there'd be nothing
wrong with it you know when it comes to
who to trust
where is Washington at at this point
well I because you asked it that way I
think many people point out that call me
testified under oath the president has
not done that and knowing that he
understands the consequences of saying
things under oath and standing by what
he's wrote and what he said there may be
a little more credibility right now at
least with Comey and the minds of many
in Washington how surprising was was it
to hear Comey acknowledged that he
leaked this information in hopes that it
would lead to the appointment of action
I'm glad you brought that up because I
think it was one of the most revealing
and important moments of the whole thing
there is nothing inherently illegal with
leaking the president and his supporters
are saying he's a leaker well there's
nothing wrong with being a leaker unless
it's classified information obviously
that's against the law
but what he did there I think was a big
favor to all of us journalists he
explained to the public why it is
government and former government
officials feel compelled sometimes to
share information that they believe
needs to get out there for us to
disseminate and report publicly there
was nothing illegal based on the
analysis of legal experts with a former
government official sharing his notes of
a meeting with his boss that were not
classified and we know the president is
going to be or his lawyer says he's
going to be suing or putting forth a
lawsuit with the Justice Department's
inspector general and it would be remiss
of us not to mention that this was
actually infrastructure week right uh
the president's priorities legislatively
in Congress when they've been scuttled
no and it's another important thing to
remember look there were the house this
week essentially repealed the dodd-frank
financial regulatory reforms that the
Obama administration put in place they
literally were voting as Comey testified
the Senate is struggling to come up with
a plan to undo the Affordable Care Act
what they're still working on it and
they'd like to get it done by the end of
July that work all continues and there
are people paying attention to it if
anything tomi yeah and if anything Comey
may have at least for a few days
diverted attention away from the fact
that Senate Republicans at least are
struggling to come up with a plan ed
O'Keefe always good to see you thank you
serious